Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast,
you guys are in for a treat today
because my guest is none other,
than the organizational psychologist,
TED talker extraordinaire,
and multiple New York Times bestselling author Adam Grant.
This is a guy who was named Wharton's top rated Professor,
seven years in a row, seven years straight.
He's recognized as one of the world's most cited,
most prolific and most influential researchers in business,
economics and work life balance.
He's been featured everywhere,
his TED talks have garnered more than 20 million views.
And his books include "Give and Take,"
"Originals," "Option B," which he co authored
with Sheryl Sandberg and his new banger,
certainly be another massive culture shifting bestseller
is titled, "Think Again,"
I cannot recommend this book enough.
I'm a super fan of Adams, have been for a long time,
and could not be more excited
to have such a luminary on the show.
But before we dive in, we're brought to you today
by the Plantpower Meal Planner, everything you need
to finally dial in your nutrition in 2021.
For just $1.90 a week, it provides you access
to literally 1000s of customizable, delicious, nutritious,
easy to prepare plant based recipes
that are updated regularly,
with built in automatic grocery delivery
of everything you need plus access to our team
of amazing nutrition coaches, on the ready
to answer all your questions, seven days a week.
To learn more and sign up visit meals.richroll.com,
literally for the price of a cup of coffee,
you can watch your life change.
Again that's meals.richroll.com.
Okay, hit that subscribe button if you haven't already.
And without further ado,
let's get into it with the great Adam Grant.
Well, I'm just absolutely delighted to be able
to share some space with you today.
I've been a big fan of your work for a very long time.
Congrats on the success of the new book, "Think Again."
I just checked like an hour ago,
I think it's like number six on Amazon,
you're killing it right now, people are really enjoying it.
And I'm really excited to dive into it with you.
Before we do that though,
can we geek out on Michigan for a minute?
We have to, we have multiple things to geek out on.
Let me just say thank you, your story obviously
has been a huge inspiration to so many people.
But every time I look at what you've accomplished
as an athlete, I just think, I don't know how you function
in the world, I would love to have your endurance.
Well, that sensibility is mutual,
because I'm fascinated with how you function in the world.
I don't know how you get so much stuff done
and how you excel in so many areas.
But, perhaps we can get into it a little bit.
I mean, we have, you know, I'm much older than you but,
like yourself, I grew up in Michigan,
we moved to Washington DC when I was like seven or eight.
But I'm from Grosse Pointe, my dad was a Detroit lawyer.
My mom was an educator, I was a swimmer, you were a diver,
everybody in my family bleeds Maize And Blue,
and it's just cool to talk to somebody
who's somewhat of the same world.
And I think we might even know
some of the same people from that world.
Like when you went to Harvard,
was Joe Brunel still the swim coach there?
No, I think it was Tim Murphy when I got there.
That was, okay, so a little bit later.
I vividly recall I had a kind of an inflection point
in my life when I went to University of Michigan
on a recruiting trip for the swim team
and had some interesting moments with Bruce Kimball
and met Dick Kimball and you know,
I'm sort of connected to that community.
My grandfather was captain of the University
of Michigan swim team like back in like 1929,
under Matt Mann who the pool is named after.
Amazing, I didn't realize your roots were this deep, okay.
Yeah, my dad went to law school at Michigan,
my mom went to University of Michigan so, lots of overlap.
Yeah, there's a ton of overlap here.
So we share mom's a teacher, dad's a lawyer,
Detroit suburbs, I found out after I became a diver
that my grandmother had been a diver.
She never had mentioned it to me,
and it just came out one day.
My mom went to Michigan, my uncle is the world's
most rabid Michigan fan and went to law school there,
and I think he hasn't missed an in person game in 50 years.
And I think not going to Michigan
for college probably broke my mom's heart.
(Rich laughs)
What are you doing?
It's like leaving a religion?
I know, especially there's something unique
about Michigan in that regard too.
It deftly was similar in my case as well.
You felt that too and then wow,
so that's also diving lower.
I mean, the the Kimball family, obviously they,
I guess they belong to a place of their own.
I remember, I actually thought about not applying
to Michigan for undergrad, because I was so terrified
of the thought of having Dick Kimball as a diving coach.
I remember, you know, friends who insisted
on only doing one in three meters springboard,
being forced to become 10 meter platform divers,
and then coughing up blood when they crash.
I didn't wanna be that guy.
Yeah, I mean, it's legendary.
And I've told this story before, but the experience
that I had on this recruiting trip, I was at a party,
a house party after swimming and diving me.
And Bruce Kimball handed me a beer,
and then he proceeded to perform the greatest party trick
that I'd ever seen, where he did a standing back flip,
holding a cup of beer without spilling any of it,
and I just thought that was the most amazing thing
I ever had seen, then I went on my own journey
with alcohol and alcoholism and recovery,
and of course, the story of Bruce's is pretty well told
and the kind of tragic circumstances that befell him.
So sad.
Yeah.
Did you dive at Harvard?
I did, and you swam at Stanford, right?
I did, yeah, did you dive all four years
or just a year or two?
I stopped after my first year, how'd you guess?
I don't know, you got too busy with other things
that seem to compel your attention.
That's exactly what happened.
Yeah, well, the new book is amazing,
I can't think of a better book,
more suited for this particular moment
than the subjects that you're talking about right now.
And in thinking about the book,
and kind of culture at large, you know,
I've spent a lot of time just thinking about
how we communicate right now.
And my sense is that we are so increasingly calcified
in our belief systems and the identities
that we form around them, and this is further intensified
by social media algorithms
that serve up what we wanna hear that,
enhances our confirmation bias,
the kind of tribes that we form online
and in our analog lives that we're kind of,
queuing our membership in good standing too.
And there's, in my sense,
there seems to be a velocity behind that,
like it's becoming more and more intense,
and its environmental, right?
The idea being that this is just kinda happening
to us without any willful input on our part.
And the antidote, which is the thesis of your book
requires a great deal of thought and presence
of mind and intentionality.
And I see it almost like a war between these two worlds.
And it's difficult to be sanguine about the future,
given the amount of intentionality
that's required to kind of rebut
the forces that be out there
that are marshaling us in the opposite direction?
I think that's true, I think it's part of the reason
that I wanted to write "Think Again," is to try to unpack,
is there anything we can do to get more open minded
and to encourage other people to be that way too?
I think I came out more hopeful than I started.
I think for a while this book was that project
that I hope someone else would pursue,
someone else go figure this out?
Get people to choose mental flexibility
over foolish consistency.
Get people to be humble and curious,
as opposed to arrogant and adjust, nobody wrote the book.
And eventually, I said, "All right, I need to take this on."
Obviously you've been working on this book for a while.
And it is current in the sense that it tackles COVID
in some regard, but obviously predates the capital,
insurrection, and aspects of QAnon and some of the other,
kind of things that we're seeing unfold right now,
when you were watching the capital insurrection,
how are you thinking about the ideas presented
in the book and how these these things kind of coalesce?
It was a shock, was the first thing, I never thought,
that an insurrection would happen in America.
It's something you read about happening in other countries,
and thank your lucky stars that we don't live
in one of those countries.
And you know, as an organizational psychologist,
I've spent most of my careers trying
to study things that are timeless,
and I've really deliberately resisted the timely,
because I'm interested in ideas, not news.
I'm interested in you know, in rigorous evidence,
not current events, and yet, this idea of thinking again,
I finished the book right around a time when we're dealing
with the greatest polarization I've ever seen,
and then an attack on our very democracy.
And my first thought was,
what everyone's now calling the big lie that,
the election was stolen from Donald Trump.
If we could have gotten many people to rethink
their belief in that lie, it's possible
the insurrection wouldn't have happened at all.
And my next thought was, okay,
most of these people don't seem to think
that they're undermining democracy.
They think they're saving democracy.
And that requires a whole reexamination,
of not just a belief, but a belief system, a worldview.
And I don't I know that I know how to tackle that.
I think I have some ideas and insights about how to begin
to chip away at some of those wrong beliefs but,
I think it's an extreme, I guess my reaction was,
there's a sequel to this book that needs to be written
about conspiracy theories, about false news,
that is very different from how I was trying
to deal with what I thought was everyday resistance
to admitting that you're wrong,
and to knowing what you don't know.
And I think what your question makes me wonder is,
is the everyday version of that now extreme enough
that we need that book for more people than I realized.
Yeah, I would like to read that book,
I think there is something qualitatively different
now about the way that we are magnetized by certain ideas.
And the conspiracy theory is its own kind of genius
in all of this, I mean, you did talk about it in the book,
you have the example of the flat earther,
and you have that graphic, that's circular graphic.
But when you think about conspiracy theories, in general,
you're dealing with a set of people who are under the belief
that they're the ones who are thinking more open minded
about this idea.
They're the ones who have taken the red pill,
they're seeing things that are, seeing things more clearly,
they're standing outside of the conventional wisdom.
And that makes it very different than some other kind
of well held belief that informs identity.
It does and it is.
I think this is, it's a huge uphill battle.
I've been reading a lot lately about the psychology
of conspiracy theories, why people adopt them,
and especially why or when
they might be willing to reconsider them.
And I think it's hard to have this conversation
without talking about cognitive dissonance, right?
Dating back to the classic Leon Festinger work,
which basically said, "If you've already committed
to a belief, then any threats to that belief,
if they force you to treat the world
as a less pleasant place for you to challenge your ego,
to put aside, you know, pre existing commitments you've made
to walk back statements you made in public,
that it's easier just to assimilate whatever's going on
into the statements you've already made,
and defend your long standing beliefs,
because then you avoid the discomfort of doubt,
and you get the comfort of conviction."
And I think that part is clear, right?
We understand why that happens.
I think the the undoing, the rethinking,
the unlearning of those beliefs is a heck of a lot harder.
And I think the most interesting thing
that I've learned lately is that there's some research
on what's called the cynical genius illusion,
where when somebody is cynical,
people tend to assume that means that they're smart,
because they don't accept things at face value.
It's actually the opposite.
People who are extremely cynical tend to be lower
in intelligence than their peers.
And, of course, there's a big difference
between cynicism and skepticism, right?
Cynicism is not believing anything you hear.
And skepticism is being a critical thinker and saying,
"Show me the evidence."
And one of the reasons that cynicism seems to emerge,
is it's a defense mechanism against being manipulated.
It's a defense mechanism that people gravitate toward,
if they get manipulated a lot,
because they're not that smart.
And I think the ways that we try to attack that are just,
it's like dumping fuel on a fire.
Because the first thing that you know that quote, unquote,
the elite does, or that the mainstream media does,
or that universities do, is we go and accuse people
of believing stupid things.
And their fear is that they're not smart,
and that's why they're clinging
to these conspiracies in the first place,
because they make them feel smart.
And so I think we need to be really careful about you know,
about threatening people's intelligence,
about questioning people's ability
to form judgments and reason.
And I think there are better ways to surface that,
which we could talk about,
but that was an aha moment for me.
Yeah, it seems like although intelligence,
IQ and EQ are important, we also have to consider,
other aspects of people's lives, like the extent
to which they're disenfranchised, they're alienated,
they're frustrated in their path and how those things,
motivate people to cottoned on to ideas
that otherwise they would think better of.
Yeah, I think that's right.
And one of the things I've learned,
and you know this from the book,
but I haven't, I certainly didn't think much
about how to apply it to these kinds of conspiracy theories
when I was writing the book.
It turns out that how questions
tend to be more powerful than why questions,
you go to somebody who believes something
that you think is is not consistent with the truth,
and you ask them why they believe what they believe,
and they have a bunch of pre made reasons
that they find compelling.
If instead, you ask them, "Well, how did that come to be?
Or how does that work?"
They're much more likely to see the gaps
in their own understanding and to recognize
the complexity of the issue.
And I actually had a chance to apply this recently.
I was talking with a friend who believes
in some vaccine conspiracies,
that the government and Big Pharma are in cahoots
to basically pull the wool over your eyes and convince you
that vaccines are much safer than they really are.
I said, "Look, first of all, some conspiracies are real,
let's put that on the table,
and we can make a list of them.
Secondly, I know that there are plenty of vaccines
that have documented side effects and risks.
And we can look even at the published evidence,
right in peer reviewed journals and say,
'Look, this is a complex issue.'
What I wanna understand though,
is that if this is so much worse than you think it is,
why is there not a single scientist within here,
who's willing to go against the establishment, right?
In a world where the incentive is to be right,
not to just toe the party line?
And also, why can you not find a single credible journalist,
who wants to win a Pulitzer Prize
for exposing this conspiracy?"
And he couldn't really answer those questions.
And then I went a step further.
And I said, "Okay, and just helped me think
through how a giant government bureaucracy,
and all these pharma companies,
wouldn't have a single internal whistleblower?
And how they, you think they're incompetent, right?
You told me they're incompetent,
how would they have even orchestrated this
to keep the facts from everybody who's in that world?"
And as he thought through how to do this, he said,
"Well, you know, maybe they couldn't have maybe, you know,
people just haven't wanted to publish the studies that,
they cast doubt on vaccine efficacy or safety,
and maybe those are under represented
in the peer reviewed journals."
And that was a much more reasonable place that he started.
Right, so the idea and this was the subject
of this new york times opinion piece, basically,
that came out the other day,
the idea being that you approach these conversations,
rather than from the paradigm that you outlined in the book,
which is, as prosecutor as preacher, or as politician,
but rather lead with curiosity, ask a lot of questions,
and receive the answers to those questions without judgment,
but rather, more curiosity.
That's the goal.
Is that accurate?
Yeah, I think that's a great summary of both the mindset
of approaching this like a scientist, and saying,
"Look, I'm not gonna preach that I'm right,
I'm not gonna prosecute you for being wrong.
But I'm also not gonna be a politician,
and just tell you what you wanna hear,
to try to campaign for your approval."
What I'm gonna do is, I'm gonna as a scientist,
I'm gonna say, "Rich, this is totally fascinating to me,
that your beliefs are so different from mine.
And I genuinely wanna understand them better.
And if you could help me make sense of how this works,
and how this played out.
And then, I also wanna understand,
I'm sure I have some beliefs that are wrong,
and I suspect you also do too, right?
Nobody, omniscient, I'd love to understand
what kind of information would lead you
to consider changing your mind?
And I'm also thrilled to talk
about what might change my mind.
And then the hope is, we're both gonna find out
that our knowledge was incomplete
through this conversation."
And, of course, it doesn't work if that's a tactic, right?
Because the other person will see right through it.
But if you adopt what counseling psychologists
called motivational interviewing, and you really try
to understand the person's reasons for change,
and what would lead them to consider shifting
their opinion a little bit,
then you might surface information
that would lead them to change their own mind.
Right, so let's dig into that a little bit deeper,
but maybe we can start with elaborating
a little bit more on this prosecutor,
preacher, politician, rubric that you've set up here.
The original idea comes from a colleague of mine,
Phil Tetlock, who's studied political psychology
and social psychology most of its career.
And Phil observed that in decision making, in judgment,
we spend a lot of time thinking like preachers,
prosecutors and politicians.
And we're usually not aware of it when we're doing it.
A preacher mindset is essentially believing
that you've already seen the light,
and now you have to go and proselytize
to everybody else and get them on board.
So you've drunk the intellectual Kool-Aid,
and now your job is to serve it.
A prosecuting mindset is more about,
proving everyone else wrong,
and winning your side of the case.
And then a politician mindset is really about saying,
"Okay, I've got some constituents here,
and I need to lobby for their buy in, I want their support."
And my big worry Rich was when I learned
about this framework, I thought,
okay, preaching and prosecuting,
those stop you from thinking again.
Because if I know I'm right, and I'm sure you're wrong,
I don't need to budge in any of my opinions
or any of the knowledge that I hold,
I just need to convince you to do that.
And in politician mode,
we see people sounding a lot more flexible,
but it's really just adjusting what they say to fit in,
it's not actually changing what they believe internally,
and that's just basically flip flopping.
Yeah, I think I fall mostly
into the politicking camp as a--
Really, as I'm surprised to hear you say that,
really, why would you say that?
Well, I would have guessed, just because of the way
that you've inspired so many people,
I would have guessed that preaching might be
the default of those three for you.
Preaching is very uncomfortable for me,
I'm much more interested in approval
and being liked to a default, in a not so great way,
like I've really made major life decisions based on approval
or doing the socially accepted.
I mean, I was a lawyer for over a decade,
trying to jam a square peg
into a round hole for way too long,
and very reluctant to get out of it,
out of fear of social repercussions
and familial expectations and the like.
And, you know, I would sit in depositions,
or in hearings and just see the gray
and everything and just felt like I'm a really bad advocate,
because I really wanna appreciate the nuance
and all of this and can't we just all get along?
Like, I'm conflict averse, I'm a people pleaser.
And you know, I host these podcasts,
and I wanna be challenging in the conversations, but also,
I only have the people on that I respect and admire.
So I'm sitting here, you know, and if I'm being honest,
it's like I want Adam to like me, I want Adam to respect me.
You know, that's like, you know, just calling myself out
in a vulnerable way over like my own motivations.
And so I spent a lot of time thinking about that.
But I also, I wanna throw like a little bit
of a test case out to you.
So I've been vegan for about 14 years now.
And I guess for better or worse part,
that's part of my identity.
And I've spent a lot of time thinking about how I,
embody that ethos, how I carry that message,
how I advocate for something that I believe in,
and I've realized that for my own personal makeup,
I don't feel, it doesn't feel natural
to me to be a preacher about it.
I'm not interested in taking other people's inventory
and criticizing their decisions,
I don't think it's effective.
And I kind of settled into a mode that's a little bit
outside of your paradigm, which is this idea
of being kind of a lighthouse, like, if I live my life well
and equip myself as an athlete, as you know,
somebody who is excelling intellectually, mentally,
emotionally, and just living well,
it acts more like a magnet or attract a beam
that will bring the the receptive audience to me,
who might be willing or interested to hear about it.
And it also goes back to 12 Step and how I got sober
and the tools that I learned in the program,
which are all about not giving advice,
but just sharing your experience.
And so I'm curious about how that fits into how you think
about these ideas of influencing people
and getting people to kind of open up their minds
and consider different concepts.
Wow, I think that's brilliant.
I'm kicking myself now
because if we had had this conversation a year ago,
I would have written that into "Think Again."
Well, now I'm bummed, I wish I'd met you earlier.
It's not my idea though, but it's just something that seems
to work better than any of these other three options,
although it doesn't start with a P,
not with a P word for it.
It's not alliterative.
And you know, I think I think you articulated it
so beautifully, though.
There's a lot to react to there,
so I wanna double click on a few things you said,
let's just start with the lighthouse idea.
I think that might be the most compelling workaround
that I've, I don't even wanna call it a workaround,
that's, I think that's not doing justice to it.
It's the most compelling solution I can think of,
to the tension between what I guess
was my preferred alternative
to preaching prosecuting and politicking,
which is thinking like a scientist, and the need if you want
to influence people in the world to do some preaching.
And I've always been uncomfortable with that tension,
because I guess I should take a step back and just say,
thinking like a scientist is what I would love
for more people to do more often.
And I don't mean, you have to go and wear a white coat
all the time, or carry around test tubes,
or even own a microscope, right?
What I mean is that just the broadest idea of science
is the pursuit of knowledge and truth.
And if your identity is anchored in being a scientist,
it means that you don't have to stick
to a certain set of beliefs at any one time,
you wanna find out what's gonna be effective,
or what the right way is to live your values.
And that means when you form an opinion,
it's a hypothesis, you can go out and test it,
you can observe, you can interact, you can run experiments.
And the hope is that you're as excited to find out
that you were wrong as you are to prove that you were right.
Because either way, you've potentially learned something.
And I would argue even you learn more when you discover
that your hypothesis was false, than when you validate it.
And yet, Phil Tetlock, when I talked to him first
about this framework saying,
"Okay, I want everyone to think more like scientists."
He said, "Well, yeah, but sometimes you have
to talk much more like a preacher in order to be heard."
You know, let's just look at any pundit on TV,
or any leader who gives an inspiring speech.
And I've never liked that as something that you have to do.
And I think you just gave an alternative,
which is to say, "Okay, I can think like a scientist,
I can test in my own life, whether I'm gonna be at my best
in an iron man, when I go vegan, right?"
That's an experiment you ran.
And then once I do that, if I'm willing to share
what I've learned from that, and I talk about that publicly,
I don't have to tell other people to do it,
I don't have to preach about it, I'm just telling my story.
And that will draw people to me,
I think that, I just think that's ingenious.
Well, it's effective, it seems to be more effective.
And I think it's all you know, a sort of corollary to that,
for me is a more kind of Buddhist
or Eastern philosophical perspective on this,
which is that I'm not attached to whether
or not I'm convincing anybody to change,
like, I'm just I'm carrying this certain vibration.
I'm happy to talk about issues that I care about
if you approach me or you're interested.
But I'm not interested in proselytizing.
I'm interested in, you know, living my best life.
And it's this idea of attraction rather than promotion,
which is core to the whole 12 Step philosophy.
Yes, and it's so consistent
with this stance of motivational interviewing,
which is, I'm not here to force you to change.
I'm here to help you if I can,
uncover your own motivation for change,
but that's up to you.
And I think the person on the receiving end of it,
feels the difference between somebody
who is really wed to an outcome, versus somebody who's like,
"Hey, I'm just telling you this, like it's your business
what you do with this information or not."
It's such a paradox, because my biggest bias
is going into prosecutor mode.
It just, I think the cartoon that could be my life story,
is the one where this guy is sitting in a computer,
and his wife says, "What's wrong?"
And he says, "Someone is wrong on the internet."
(Rich laughs)
Right yeah.
And he can't sleep, and that's me, I just...
As a social scientist, when somebody believes something
that goes against the weight of the evidence,
I think I felt for a long time,
like it was my moral responsibility
to try to correct them.
And not only was that way too high and mighty of me
and self righteous, it also didn't work,
to your point about effectiveness.
Have you, I don't see you trolling people
on Twitter though, like you don't get involved
in that kind of stuff.
No, I but I have, I've written some articles
that I think led people to really misjudged me, as you know,
as being actually a close colleague of mine,
one of the people who I consider a part
of my challenge network, not my support network.
One of my most thoughtful critics said to me,
"Do you wanna spend your career
being a professional debunker?"
I said, "No, I wanna build ideas up, not tear them down.
But I also believe that if somebody is selling snake oil,
that we should make the world aware of that."
And that tension has been really tricky for me.
But I think this idea of being a lighthouse and saying,
"Look, here's my analysis of the evidence,
and here's my experience applying it,
what do you make of that?"
The irony in it for me is, it really invalidates
one of my core beliefs, which is when you have a goal,
you should work as hard as you can to achieve it.
And in this case, it is very Buddhist, like you said,
letting go of the goal a little bit and saying,
"Hey look, my mission here is not to persuade,
is to share, is to teach, it's to learn."
That actually makes me more persuasive.
Precisely because I'm not trying to be persuasive.
Yeah, well, I think it gets into the mysteries
of the human mind in the sense that, what wins the day,
isn't necessarily the most soundproof logical argument.
More often than not, at least in my own experience,
and I'm curious what you make of this,
it's if you can really emotionally connect with the person
that you're talking to and engender some level of trust,
which has nothing to do with logic, that ultimately can be
the lever that moves the needle more than, you know,
the, you know, the facts of the case,
or the scientific aspects of whatever it is
that you're discussing.
I mean, that's certainly consistent
with my read of the data.
It's stunning to me that when I think about,
these experiments that current Bendoski has run for example,
that just saying to somebody
who has a different opinion than you,
"I respect people who have clear principles,"
is enough to reduce animosity,
and lead to more openness IN a conversation.
It's one of the simplest demonstrations of your point.
And yet, it makes me think,
that maybe what you sort of sheepishly said,
is more of a politician sometimes than I would like to be,
is an advantage, because it leads you to build
that connection and that trust.
And I have to tell you, just to get back a little bit Rich,
I'm flattered that you want me to like you.
Because here I come on your show thinking,
I always wanted to be an athlete,
I was never talented enough in any sport
to become a real athlete,
I got just good enough to dive in college.
And I look at what you've achieved and think I wish I had
the endurance, that I could do 300 plus miles of running,
swimming and biking.
I wish I could have the discipline in my eating habits
and make nutrition enough of a priority in my life,
to become as fit as you've become.
And so I came on here thinking,
okay, this is completely a Trojan horse for me.
I didn't necessarily write the book
in order to have this conversation,
but part of the joy of writing a book like this is,
cool, I'm gonna come here, I'm gonna soak up
a little bit of the way that Rich Roll thinks,
and maybe I will end up adopting a better philosophy
of fitness for my own life.
So that's my secret mission for coming.
All right, well we can talk all of that,
at some later point, I'm very flattered
that you would say that and I would have
to say you know, likewise, like when you DMed me on Twitter,
I was like, I couldn't believe that you've DMed me,
I was so excited, so it's a mutual admiration society here.
I'll try not to make it look like that.
But you got to stop throwing diving
under the bus, come on.
Diving deserves to be thrown under the bus.
No, it doesn't come on.
It does, let me, okay,
so let me prosecute myself on this one, right?
Because, yeah, I wanna hear your counter argument.
And I know this is more going into debate mode
than I've advocated for in the book.
But you know what, maybe we should rethink
some of the things I wrote in the spirit of the book,
I think the thing about diving is,
it looks really complex,
but it's just a very small number of skills.
Like you learn timing on the board,
so that you can jump a little bit higher, you learn
to throw your arms forward or back to create rotation.
You work on your flexibility so that you can spin faster.
You learn to twist a little bit and then you just have
to get air sense or good visuals
and put your hands in front of your head.
And a good dive takes less than two seconds to execute.
Compare that with a slog of you go into a pool,
so I learned to do a front two and a half with a full twist,
so I could flip twice, twist once dive in headfirst,
and that took me three years
of serious diving practice to do.
In six years of a life in the pool,
I could not learn to swim the butterfly stroke,
literally cannot do the butterfly,
which you competed in and you can swim faster
in a butterfly then I can swim freestyle.
How is what I learned not easier than what you mastered?
Because to each his own, like I could never,
I couldn't dive to save my life
no matter how much I practice.
So anybody who's very--
Did you try?
I did, yeah, and anybody who's very proficient
in a specific thing tends to,
under index for how difficult that thing is.
So basically, all I'm saying to you is, celebrate the fact
that you are a diver and stop saying that it's like
the nerd sport and all of that, and that maybe
the divers will be happy, happier, when they do that.
But I'm interested in, because you have this this background
as a diver and as an athlete, is there a nexus
between what you learned in sport, and this,
incredible, superhuman focus that you have, and this,
ability to be productive at a level
that most people can't comprehend?
Well, I don't accept any of the premises of the question,
but I realized there's a perception
in the world that I get a lot done,
and it's incredibly strange to me, because most days,
I feel totally unproductive.
And I don't know if I just have unreasonable goals
for myself or how to explain that.
But I think one of the things that diving,
I don't know if I learned it in diving,
or if it just reinforced the value of it for me,
and then it became more hardwired, was just the value
of focusing on one thing at a time.
The number of people I know who are multi-taskers,
not necessarily even in the minute, but in the day,
is much greater than I would like it to be.
I think that computers are great at parallel processing.
As humans, we are built to be serial processors.
And I don't just mean that, if I'm checking my phone,
while we're talking that I'm not gonna be coherent, I mean,
that if I'm trying to accomplish two things today,
I'm gonna do both of those less effectively,
than if I just have one goal today.
And that was what diving really was, it was,
yeah, I would go to practice.
And I would max out, usually it was two and a half
or three hours before I start to get blisters on my feet.
Or, you know, from repeated days of practice, or,
you know, my shoulders would start to hurt or,
you know, my form would just start to fall apart,
and I needed to take a break.
But then it meant I'm studying the video of my own practice,
to really internalize what my coach is telling me.
I'm analyzing what changes I might wanna make
that my coaches didn't see.
I'm heading over to a trampoline to practice some
of the techniques that don't require water.
I'm working on my stretching.
And that single mindedness was I think,
other than having incredible coaches,
was the only reason that I got good at diving.
And it's just, it's kind of, it's startling to me,
it's, startling is the wrong word, it's mesmerizing to me,
that people think you can be good at anything,
when you're trying to be good at multiple things.
And I'm not saying you can't master multiple things
in a year or even in a month.
But what I wanna do is, I wanna have not work life balance,
or even project project balance, I wanna have rhythm,
which means you know, today I've got one song
that I'm playing or better yet,
I've got one verse of that song.
And then tomorrow, we'll go over to the course.
Right, I mean that dovetails pretty nicely
into this idea that you have
about attention management versus time management,
and your ability to be productive is calibrated
with your ability to really invest your attention
and your focus on one thing at a time.
Yeah, I think that my big frustration with time management
is that the more you try to optimize your calendar,
the more aware you become of how many hours you waste
in the day in the week.
And that just is, it's discouraging and deflating to me.
And I decided at some point that what I wanted to do
was get better at managing my attention.
And that meant that I had to have clarity
about the people and the projects that mattered to me.
And then if I was laser focused on those,
it wouldn't matter how long anything took,
because my time is aligned with my values and my goals.
And I think that, in some cases, that just means,
well, now I guess what I would say is,
attention management sometimes gets me in trouble,
because my attentional filters are so high,
that my peripheral vision gets gone.
And if I'm locked into a goal of finishing a task today,
let's say I'm writing an op-ed,
like that "New York Times," one that you referenced,
I set a goal a few weeks ago of finishing a draft of it.
And I was late to two meetings, I've missed one deadline,
and I think I'm lucky to be in a job
where I have the freedom to set my own deliverables.
And I've also let everyone I know who works with me,
know that one of my biggest vices is,
that I have a chronic inability to disengage from a task,
until it's done to my satisfaction,
or at least until I've made real progress on it.
Because I think those moments of flow, of deep work are,
I don't wanna say they're rare, but they're precious,
they need to be protected.
And I wanna get every ounce of creativity and energy
out of them when I get into them.
Yeah, I mean, you can't task switch
when you're in that process of creation.
And there is a real qualitative difference between makers
and managers, like makers really need to protect that time
to do the thing that they do.
And you can't toggle in between tasks
when you're in the process of trying to make something.
And so it's not surprising that it would compel you
to be late or miss other things,
because the priority has to go towards taking advantage
of that flow when it descends upon you.
Whereas the manager mindset is very different.
They're task switching all the time,
and it's about their interactions with lots of people
and lots of emails and meetings,
and all of that kind of stuff, which are really,
just massive distractions to anybody
who is more of a maker or creator.
Yes, and I think this is one of the opportunities
in front of us now, with remote work becoming very real
for millions, if not hundreds of millions
or billions of people.
I keep thinking of this Leslie Parla experiment,
where she said, "What if we just give people quiet time,
three mornings a week, where they're told
don't schedule meetings, no interruptions,
you can actually just concentrate on focused work?"
And she did this at a Fortune 500 company in India
with engineers, if people were encouraged
to do that themselves, 47% above average productivity.
If the organization instituted it as a policy,
it said, "Look, we mean this Tuesday, Thursday,
Friday, no meetings, no interruptions before noon,"
65% above average productivity.
And if you break that down, what's going on there?
Well, some of it is you are just benefiting
from more flow and more deep work.
But some of it is also just plain efficiency
that you check your inbox after lunch,
having had a productive morning.
And you realize that six people had the same question.
And now instead of having six different conversations,
you can call all those people together in one meeting,
it only takes one hour out of your day,
and then you've also helped those people build a network
of acquaintances, or maybe even strangers who didn't work
realize that they were working on similar problems.
And I've watched a lot of organizations just say,
"You know what, we can't protect people's time,
because we have customers or we have clients
that impose demands on us."
And my response to them has been,
"Well, actually, don't you think this is how you teach
your clients to be more effective and productive too?
To say, look, we are here to be available to you
and helpful to you wherever we can.
And in order to do the best job,
not only reacting to your problems,
and fighting every fire that comes up,
but also really rethinking how we solve problems
in the first place or better yet how to prevent problems
at scale, we need some protected time.
And so of course, we're happy to hear
from you if it's an emergency.
But we're gonna have one day a week
where we don't schedule meetings,
or we're gonna have a couple mornings a week,
where we don't take calls.
And we want you to know, that's part of how we serve you."
It's interesting, I mean, it's counterintuitive
in the sense that from a managerial perspective,
you would think that people would then just use that time
to go fuck off and do whatever they want,
they're not gonna actually use that
for some kind of deep work, they're gonna go, you know,
I don't know, go run errands or something like that.
Well, if you're a bad manager,
that's probably what they will do.
Because you haven't earned any trust or loyalty.
But if you're a manager who instead of being a micromanager,
is a macro manager, who says,
"My job is to figure out the purpose
and the mission of the team in the organization,
and then help you identify your unique individual role
and see your contribution here.
And then I'm gonna get out of the way and not tell you
how to do everything or when to do everything."
You get a lot of intrinsic motivation in response to that.
And we've got, at this point, almost half a century
of evidence on the benefits
of what I guess classically Douglas McGregor
would have called a Theory Y As opposed to Theory X approach
where, you know, whether you believe that people are lazy
and can't be trusted, or people are intrinsically motivated
by mastery and learning and purpose,
those beliefs often become self fulfilling prophecies
and you get exactly what you expected.
Yeah, interesting, well, as somebody
who is spent their entire career kind of devoted
to better understanding the psychology of the workplace,
this past year has to be, you know, fascinating
for you to see the ascent of the home office and you know,
everything that COVID has has brought us,
and the disruptions in how we work.
So what are some of the insights that you've been able
to develop out of this, you know,
very strange and unique year that we've just experienced?
There have been a lot.
Not surprisingly, this is the experiment
that nobody opted into.
And since we're stuck with it,
we might as well be learning from it.
I think what are my first, I guess,
one of the first revelations for me was Ethan Bernstein,
and Hayley Blunden collected data on just March through May,
how is communication changing, now that essentially
everybody who could, is working remotely?
And they found that communication with strong ties went up
about 40% on average, that with your closest colleagues,
your boss, your direct reports,
the clients that you're in touch with regularly,
you knew you weren't just gonna run into them,
or you weren't flying out to see them,
and you worked hard to schedule extra opportunities
to connect with them, usually over Zoom.
Communication with weak ties, though,
your more distant acquaintances,
your suppliers, the mentor you occasionally talk to,
that was actually down 10%.
And this is bad news when it comes to rethinking things,
getting a fresh perspective.
Because weak ties tend to give us
more novel information than strong ties.
Strong ties tend to know the same people in the same stuff
that you do, they give you a redundant knowledge.
weak ties are traveling different circles,
they're meeting different people,
they're learning different things.
So they're much more likely to open up fresh access
to a creative idea, and because we're not having
those spontaneous creative collisions, like we used to
before the pandemic, I think one of the things we have
to figure out is how do we engineer interactions
between people and their more distant acquaintances,
or allow them even to learn from strangers?
And I don't think we have good,
I don't think we have good practices yet to figure that out.
How have you navigated that Rich?
Well, I'm very lucky in the sense that I've been able
to continue to pursue my living
where a lot of people are not so lucky,
so I feel extremely grateful.
A big part of the show that I do,
which is the the gravamen of my vocation,
is sitting across from another individual live
and doing it in person.
And, you know, we've set up safety protocols,
and I've been able to do that to some extent, but you know,
like, what we're doing right now, some of them
have been forced to be, you know, on a digital platform,
which is not my preference.
Like, for me, this experience is all about,
like trying to connect as deeply as possible
with the person that I'm talking to.
And very often these people become part of my life,
maybe they become part of my challenge network,
or my support network,
or my board of advisors, or just friends.
And that's incredibly valuable to me,
I mean, it's a gift to be able to share, you know,
the wisdom of people like yourself, with so many people.
But the enriching aspect of it
for me is the in person connection.
And my kind of personal strategy
with all of these conversations
is that the emotional connection comes first.
It's less about the information, like I trust
that if I can connect with the person who's sitting across
from me, find a way in to really identify with them,
that whatever information needs
to be imparted will be imparted,
and I just try to be as present as possible for that,
and I'm able to achieve that, to some extent,
when I'm looking at you on a screen, but it's not the same.
Well, it still comes through loud and clear to me.
I can feel it, I can see it, I can hear it.
I should say first of all, I would love to be friends.
In case that's on your goal list already.
Okay I get it, I'm gonna call you my friend now.
Sorry, I mean, we're friends, consider it done.
I mean, I felt, coming in I felt like I knew you already
because I've followed your work with such great interest.
And it's so clear what you stand for
and what your values are, that I felt like I knew you.
So there was that connection,
even if swimmers and divers are supposed
to not get along, but I felt coming in that--
It's the weirdest pairing of two sports
into one that it shouldn't exist.
I'm Malcolm (indistinct) would have
a lot of opinions on that.
(Rich laughs)
It's like, well, these two things both involve water.
let's put them on a team together.
I guess there's also a masochistic element of both though,
which is, I think both of us opted into more deliberate pain
than many sports require.
I don't remember basketball or soccer ever hurting nearly
as much as diving did.
Yeah, swimming is a glutton for people
who enjoy self punishment, I can tell that.
But Rich, I did wanna ask you.
I've been curious about, yeah,
there's just, I think we're gonna have a wealth
of data in the next few years about in person
versus video, versus audio interactions.
And one thing I have noticed, I'm also drawn to the rapport
and the connection, and I've always been the person
who if I have a choice, I wanna sit down
in a room with someone because I can,
I feel like I can bond with him more.
I also, it's easier to get into that burstiness of you know,
we're just, we have this energy flying back and forth,
and the conversation is literally bursting with ideas.
I have noticed though, in the past few years of podcasting,
that I think I have deeper conversations sometimes
when I'm not in the room with people.
And it's because I'm less attuned to this question of, okay,
how did they react to what I just said?
Do they like me, you know, or was that awkward,
or did it build rapport?
And I'm much more comfortable with an awkward pause.
I'm much more interested in trying to figure out,
where's this conversation gonna take us?
And so I wonder if there's a purity of discussion,
that comes from distance, what has that been like for you?
That's very interesting.
There's certainly some truth in that.
The question that popped into my head
when you were describing that,
is whether there's a difference
between when you're doing it on Zoom, and you're looking
at the person versus an audio only platform
where you don't have to worry about like,
I don't wanna look down at my notes,
I wanna maintain eye contact with you.
But if we were doing this on a different platform,
where we weren't doing video, and I could be staring
at my notes, maybe I would have better questions chambered,
but I also wouldn't be as fully present
for the experience that's happening.
Yeah, there's a trade off there.
Yeah, so I don't know, and to kind of answer
the other aspect of your question, you know,
how is this experience bad,
I mean outside of the podcast itself,
I went into this pandemic thinking,
I've been training for this my whole life,
like I'm an introvert, I like my solitary time,
this is gonna be just fine, I'll be able to cancel
all these things on my calendar
that I didn't really wanna do anyway,
and focus on some deep work and just being with my family,
but none of us would have expected
that it would be going on this long.
And even you know, despite those predispositions
that I have, I do feel lonely, and I do miss my friends.
And I find myself yearning
for that interpersonal connection.
And I feel terrible for my kids who are being deprived
of experiences that, you know, no child should be deprived
of in terms of their ability to socially interact
with their peers.
Yeah, well first of all, I'm sorry to hear that,
I think I can relate to so much of that.
And I think everyone assumed going in that introverts
are gonna have an easier time with this than extroverts,
and this is another Bernstein, Blunden at all finding,
there was no difference in the well being of introverts
and extroverts during the early stages of the pandemic.
And I think that's in part
because everyone craves connection.
Even those of us who are introverts, you're one I'm one,
we are energized by interactions with other people.
We're also more likely to be overstimulated
by too much of that interaction.
And I think that's where the physiological difference
between extroverts and introverts lies,
according to the science there but,
I think that the loneliness piece
of this is real for a lot of people.
And I wonder, I think one thing I've started to rethink,
and I really underestimated,
is just how much casual interaction matters in my life.
I never thought just seeing somebody at a restaurant,
right without even talking to them necessarily.
And it never dawned on me that that was part
of feeling a sense of community,
or just deep belonging in a place.
And I think that, my hope is I'll appreciate that now,
in a way that I didn't before.
Well, in thinking about the workplace,
and what this year has taught us,
you talked a little bit about enhancements in productivity.
What do you think, what's your estimation of,
once we get back to our ability to safely interact,
like, what is gonna snap back to the way it was before,
and what's not?
I mean, we're seeing migrations
of people moving out of cities and finding,
places to live that are more affordable, etc.
So I think certainly, there's permanent implications
to this, where people are realizing they didn't need
to do a lot of the things they were doing before,
and yet, we do have to get back to some level
of healthy interpersonal interaction.
So what does that you know,
where's your thinking in terms of that?
I wish I had a crystal ball.
I think it's definitely still a mystery.
I can tell you, the data that I've seen so far
would predict a few things.
First one is Nick Blum and his colleagues just did
a nationally representative survey of 15,000 Americans.
And they found that essentially, people are expecting
to do usually somewhere between 20 and 25%
of their workdays remote, and that's taking
into account individual preferences
as well as the organic policies that are starting to emerge.
And most of that is hybrid.
That's not, you know, a bunch of companies saying,
"We're gonna be fully in the office,"
and a bunch of workplaces saying,
"We're gonna be fully remote."
That's most people and most leaders saying,
"We'd love to have people in the office three,
four days a week, and then work from anywhere the rest."
The challenge with that is,
what kinda office space do you need?
If you do you want everyone to be there three days,
then you need a huge office, and it's a major waste?
Are you gonna do shift work like a hospital,
where people come in at different times,
or even on different days?
Well, then you're missing the sense of cohesiveness
and a culture, I think those are the kinds of questions
that a lot of leaders are grappling with right now.
I think one thing we can be reasonably confident
in predicting is, we're not gonna see a return
to this giant hub, tiny spokes model,
that used to organize most workplaces, right?
where everybody's wanting to be at headquarters.
And then you see occasional people who are in satellites,
I think we're gonna see probably a much smaller hub,
and then more affordable places to work in different parts
of the country or different parts of the world
for a lot of organizations, but giant caveat on this is,
people wanna be where the most senior leader is.
They wanna be where they can get face time
with powerful people,
they wanna be where they can get mentored
by experienced experts,
and they wanna be where they think they can be part
of what is the real community.
And I don't know how, I don't see that going away.
And so I think we're still gonna end up with hubs,
they're just gonna be smaller hubs.
Right, it wasn't that long ago that the idea
of working from home was this huge benefit.
And now, the idea of getting to go into an office
just seem so appealing.
You know, it's very strange how the mind works around that.
But I would tend to agree with that.
I mean, I think it's gonna be fascinating to see.
And I'm wondering, do you have your finger on the pulse
of people's satisfaction with their vocation,
when they're working from home, like in this new situation,
like are people happier?
Like setting aside the other aspects of COVID?
Like, do they enjoy this more or are they waiting
until they can go back into the office,
like, where does that fall?
It's another giant question mark,
because we have our data pre pandemic,
when nobody had the same experience
working remotely but we do now.
And then we have data during the pandemic,
when we have all these confounds of you know,
"I'm afraid I might get COVID,
and there are limitations on what I can do
and who I can see."
My guess is though,
there's probably a net benefit to flexibility.
That doesn't mean you should be permanently remote, right?
But to have the choice to work from wherever you want,
and to do that, at least part of your time,
I think that seems to be good for well being
and the early data on this,
there was a meta analysis, Gajendran and Harrison, 2007,
they cumulated every study that had been done to date
on what was called telecommuting,
which sounds like a thing of the 1990s,
but they basically meant remote work.
And they found that as long as people came to work,
two and a half days a week, performance was higher,
satisfaction was higher, and there were no cost
to the quality of co worker relationships.
And I think that then tracks
with a lot of what we're seeing in the pandemic,
which is people don't like their jobs less on average,
when they're working remotely.
They found that they, there's some things they like better,
and there's some things they like worse,
I think the general upsides have been people love
the autonomy and freedom.
They appreciate not having to commute,
although some of them will choose to commute again.
They like also, you know, in some cases,
the fact that they get to choose just a work environment
where they're comfortable.
I think on the flip side, people miss the structure,
they miss the community, they miss the culture.
And I think we want all of those things,
so I think we're gonna mostly need to be hybrid
to get all those things.
Yeah, I mean, Zoom fatigue is real.
What's behind that for you?
Because I've been hearing a lot about this,
and I've felt it from time to time.
When you talk about Zoom fatigue,
what's contributing to that for you?
I'm not somebody who's on tons of Zoom calls,
so I might not be the best person to feel this question.
But I just, I don't like the static nature.
I don't like sitting still staring at a screen
when I don't know what it is, I can't put my finger on it,
but it makes me feel very restless.
Like, I just wanna get up and move around.
I don't know, I mean--
Got it, interesting.
I mean, it's got to be a thing that's,
not like it's gonna be in the DSM five or whatever.
But it's definitely a real condition.
I mean, what are some of the experiences
that people have shared with you about that?
What I'm seeing so far, yeah, for some people,
it's just, I'm too static, which it sounds
like it's your experience.
For some people, it's the exhaustion
of talking into a screen,
and trying to read people's facial cues or parse tone
in a way that's never quite as clear
as if you're actually in the same room.
For some people, it's a lack of a sense
of just being in the same place.
And you know, that's just interfering with connection.
And my guess is of all these factors,
just the sitting still staring at a screen,
that would probably be the biggest contributor to it.
But we have, a lot of people have the flexibility
to try to change that, right?
I've watched a lot of people say,
"Alright, I don't need to be on camera,
I'm doing walking meetings."
Or we've even agreed as a team
that we're gonna take a couple of our standing meetings,
and we're gonna make those, hey, you can do a workout,
it probably shouldn't be an intense workout,
you shouldn't go swimming, definitely, but,
you know, you can go for a walk,
or you can go for a light jog,
or even play catch outside with your kids,
during a couple of these meetings a week.
And I think that we've been too wedded
to the idea that you always have to sit
in front of a computer in order to be working,
and I just don't think that's true anymore,
and that's one of my basic list of things
we could probably rethink a little more than we do.
Yeah, I mean, I'm certainly no fan of how it's being used
in for high school education right now,
I've got a daughter who she's on Zoom
from like eight to four, doing classes,
and she's just not wired
to sit and stare at a screen like that.
And then she's got homework,
and she's in an art high school,
and then she's got her art projects.
And the stress level and the anxiety
with her is through the roof.
And I'm like, what is this for?
This is not in service to her best interest right now,
it's really deeply problematic I think.
I'm sad to hear that, and I'm also a little surprised,
because I've read evidence now,
both from a UK study and a US study,
that teenagers are actually doing better
from a well being perspective.
So lower depression, lower anxiety rates,
during parts of this pandemic.
And it seems to be the case that one of the big mechanisms
behind that is it's hard to get bullied over Zoom.
And you don't quite worry as much about what you're wearing,
and who's excluding you at the lunch table.
It's this virtual and I guess the virtual environment
is an equalizing force in some ways.
And it's almost just like at work
where it's this double edged sword,
there are things that got better,
there are things that are harder.
And I wonder if on average, that's the experience for,
at least to older kids in online school.
Yeah, I hadn't heard that before,
that's super interesting.
I mean, all the things that I'd seen were that depression
and anxiety were way higher, like on the rise
as a result of this with young people.
I think so it seems to be age specific.
I think younger kids are having a harder time,
I think for teenagers who are more tech savvy and have a lot
of the existing relationships where they can stay in touch,
and let's face it, a lot of them were just texting already.
So it's not like that everybody lost
all their in person time.
I think that piece of it seems to be different.
And then also, it's probably still too early
to have any real sense of this.
But my read from some of the initial data
is that during lockdown,
is when some of these well being benefits emerged,
where everybody was in the same remote scenario.
And yeah, I think, as we started to see more disparities
with some kids in school, some kids who are stuck remote,
I think that's probably exacerbated the problems
and maybe minimize some of the benefits to it.
Right, like there was a democratic, you know,
impact on everybody equally as a result of the lockdown.
Yeah, which is again, just like at work,
if 90% of your team is in the same place,
you don't wanna be the one person
calling in virtually, if you can avoid it.
From, you know, the Caribbean or something like that,
while everyone else is stuck in (indistinct).
I'm on the beach.
(Rich laughs)
Great to see you all.
Great, well, I want to get back
to some of the ideas in "Think Again."
And we were talking about Michigan earlier,
I mean, when I was young, we moved to Washington, DC,
which is really where I grew up.
And my dad was a government lawyer.
So we were kind of in this inside the Beltway community.
And this is like, you know, the late 70s, early 80s.
And, you know, in our neighborhood, there were Republicans,
Democrats, my next door neighbor was a was a senator like,
and I just recall, even though there were all kinds
of people on different sides of the aisle politically,
there was a level of comedy that I think has disappeared.
Like we were friends with all these people,
we could have parties and they would all come over
and everybody got along just fine,
and this is really no longer the case.
And I do find myself despairing over our ability
to commune productively and communicate effectively,
and your book is very much an antidote to that.
But whatever, you know, the Gestalt of social forces
have put us into this place, like, how is this?
You know, how does this play out for you?
Are we gonna continue on this path?
Like I know, you're looking at this mostly
from the perspective of what we can do as individuals
and organizations to rebut this, but on a more kind of,
national scale, like, how are you thinking
about the future of our ability to communicate healthily?
I've been thinking about it a lot.
And my first thought is always,
as an organizational psychologist, I don't have
the expertise to even begin to analyze this question.
We should be talking to political scientists
and sociologists, probably some anthropologists as well,
because I think we're essentially in a place now
where we've got two foreign cultures that do not like
what the other side is supposedly standing for.
And so most of what I've been doing is just a lot of reading
and a lot of asking questions to try to understand
the causes and some of the remedies better.
I don't know where we go from here.
I think that one of the things that happen,
post election, post insurrection is, I just saw people,
I really respect intellectually, get crushed.
And in some cases, people attempted
to cancel them for calling for respect.
And I don't see how we make any progress,
without giving people just the basic dignity they're owed,
as human beings.
I like this distinction that Christy Rogers
and her colleagues make, which is between owed
and earned respect, owed respect being that basic,
you are a human and therefore,
I think your ideas and your emotions matter.
And then earned respect being okay,
depending on your performance or your contribution,
or your credibility, I might listen to you more carefully,
I might take what you say
a little bit more seriously in my own life.
And I think the idea that we should abandon owed respect,
that you can solve this problem by saying,
"Well, I think you don't respect me,
and therefore I'm not gonna respect you."
Like that's first grade playground behavior.
I think that we need to be clear
about how we earn respect in this society.
And ideally, I mean, this is extreme, but I would love
to see people start keeping score a little bit.
Let's go through, you know, we have a lot of debate
about media as media and social media.
Let's go through people who make claims and predictions.
And let's actually track
who turns out to be right and wrong.
And let's hold ourselves accountable
before we have the data, for following and listening
to the people who get things right more often.
And Rich' as you know, my read of the evidence
is that people who get things right more often,
are the people who admit they're wrong more often.
And that needs to become a currency socially.
Saying you're wrong needs to be a sign
that you are willing to think like a scientist,
that you are interested in learning
and updating your beliefs,
when better logic or data come along.
And I don't know how to get us there,
but that's where I wanna go.
Well, the keeping score thing though,
is part of the problem as well,
like when you look at Twitter,
it's all about, it's not about truth or nuance,
it's about signaling to your respective tribe,
that you're a member in good standing.
And the point scoring is all about taking people down
or holding people to account for an idea
that doesn't neatly fit into the, you know,
the prescribed ideology of that particular tribe.
I don't think it has to be that way, though, right?
There are communities on Twitter that have adopted
different values and different norms.
I know academic Twitter is a popular hashtag,
and there are entire sub-fields of people.
We started with epidemiologists last spring
and continuing to the present.
We've seen it with people who are debating
hot issues across very complex fields, I think.
I mean, I've made a concerted effort to follow people
whose conclusions I disagree with,
because I admire the integrity of their thought process.
And that means I see information
that constantly questions my convictions.
But that's not a threat to me,
I don't have ego invested in that,
I'm on Twitter to learn and to teach.
And that means if I'm accessing different perspectives
from people who have high standards of rigor, I'm learning,
and I think your point is well taken, that social media,
and I think the traditional media has done this
for a long time to really rewards preaching and prosecuting.
Like the person with a sound bite that can kinda elevate
their tribe and take down the other tribe,
is the one who gets amplified the most.
But I think as consumers of information,
we have choices around that, right?
I don't have to share, I don't have to validate people,
who are just always trumpeting the party line.
What I wanna amplify are the people
who are making me think and rethink.
And I guess with one of my hats as an educator,
the place I would start working on this is in schools.
I think we know you, you read in the book
that I really did not expect this,
that if kids grow up believing in false knowledge,
like the earth is flat as an extreme example,
if you wait until middle school or high school
to try to debunk that, it's already harder.
You actually need to sort of take on science myths
in elementary school, in order to both get the principles
that are aligned with the truth, as we know it,
on the table earlier, but also to teach them
that a lot of things
that intuitively feel true to you are false,
and you need to constantly
be in the mindset of asking and learning.
And with that in mind, I would say maybe one
of the best long term investments we can make as a country,
is to say, let's teach the next generation of kids,
to be eager, enthusiastic, curious, humble re-thinkers.
Yeah, wouldn't that be nice, right?
I mean, there's so many things about education
that needs to be overhauled with respect to that,
I think, and that could be a whole other podcast,
but I think it's super important.
And one of the reasons why we homeschooled,
our kids early on to avoid some of those pitfalls.
And, you know, the future will tell us
whether that was a correct decision or not,
but so far, so good.
But I wanna get to some of the practices,
you talked about welcoming differing points
of view into your world and into your field
so that you're constantly being challenged.
But as somebody who's, you know, so successful
and kind of at the top of their field,
it would be very easy for you to become calcified
around your thinking, to surround yourself with sycophants
and people that tell you, you're great.
But, you know, what I get from you is a tremendous amount
of humility and curiosity.
And this like, desire, this thirst for learning for,
expanding your perspective.
So how can somebody who's watching this or listening
to this cultivate some aspect of that in their own lives
so that they are, you know, more vigorously challenging
their own ideas and really kind of,
for lack of a better phrase, like falling in love
with being wrong or being challenged
and relishing that as opposed to resisting it?
Thank you, I can't think of a higher compliment
than being called humble and curious.
And that's who I wanna be.
I don't think I always show up that way successfully,
but it's certainly in my value system.
And the idea that you've taken any of that from my work,
or anything I've done is a little bit encouraging.
But I don't wanna be surrounded by sycophants.
And so my first instinct is to say, wait a minute, go back,
find some moments when I lacked humility,
when I wasn't curious enough,
and help me learn from those.
And I think the motivation behind that is the same one
that you've had throughout your, I do wanna turn the tables
on you at some point in this conversation Rich,
because your whole, your story as I know it,
is you are a dedicated re thinker.
You know, everything I know about your story from you know,
rethinking, your addictions, to your exercise habits,
to your nutrition, to now what you do for a living, right?
Going from practicing law to you know,
now you're a thought leader, you're a podcaster,
you're a writer, every one of those decisions
was a major opportunity to think again
and I wanna understand better how you did that.
I saw the look on your face,
you're not gonna let me turn the tables yet.
So I will try to answer your question but--
I know you do this in lots of podcasts
and with varying degrees of willingness
on behalf of the host, I'll indulge you a little bit,
but this is this is about you.
But I will say this, I do find myself resistant
or somewhat calcified around certain ideas that I have,
that are part and parcel of my identity.
Like, I'm constantly trying not to overly identify
with the vegan thing, like that's part of who I am.
But I've actually worked very hard to make sure
that that's not like the entirety of how people know me
and I've tried to expand my curiosity in other directions.
But I feel it coming up, particularly in the context
of addiction recovery, like as somebody who got sober,
I went to a treatment center and then I've been in AA for,
over two decades at this point, it's helped me get sober,
it helped me get sober, saved my life,
continues to save my life.
I'm devoted to helping other people achieve
and maintain sobriety, being of service in that program
is a core to who I am.
And I've seen people's lives change
in such dramatic fashion.
And I'm in adherence and a proponent of this lifestyle.
And yet every single year without fail,
there'll be somebody who comes along,
who says everything you know about addiction
and recovery is wrong, AA doesn't work, here's the new way,
and I'll feel my, you know, my back goes up,
and I'll get defensive about it.
And so I'm always endeavoring to look at that
and figure out how not to be defensive
to entertain new ways of thought,
that in a manner that isn't threatening my identity.
A perfect example would be all the work that's being done
right now in psychedelics and kind of the advent of things
like Ayahuasca, which, to me is anathema to my own program,
it's not for me, and yet, I have to acknowledge
that there is a lot of amazing science coming out
right now about the impact of these substances.
And I want to approach that from a perspective
of curiosity rather than defensiveness.
But that would be one example
of where I feel it kind of percolating up.
I love that, that's exactly, I'm trying not to have a goal
of changing anybody's mind or behavior.
But if I did have that goal, it would be for people
to think exactly as you just outlined, to say,
even with my core identities,
that I may learn things next year,
that make me wanna tinker with those a little bit.
Or that lead me to say, yeah,
you know what, that's not my taste,
or it's not aligned with the way that I've chosen to live,
but I can be much more open to, and accepting
of other people's choices that might be different.
I think that would be such a great starting point
for many people.
And I guess, to answer your question.
I think, I guess what I would love people to start
if they're committed to, the idea of being open minded,
is to begin to know what they don't know.
You saw in the book, I just, I started making
a list of things that I'm ignorant about,
and my goal is for that list to grow every day.
And not to grow, because I'm ignoring
those areas of ignorance, but to grow,
because I'm constantly becoming aware,
of how many things I'm clueless about.
And I want that to do two things,
I want it one to keep me humble,
so that I don't end up spouting opinions on things
that I'm completely unqualified to weigh in on.
And two, for it to stoke that curiosity, to say,
"Well, why is it that I've never learned
anything about music?"
It's not that I don't find it interesting,
why have I as somebody who loves to learn,
why haven't I pursued that?
And is that something I wanna explore
at some point in my life, when my I sort of, I guess,
when I flip the serial processing switch in that direction?
So I think everybody could keep a list like that.
And the goal is, as you learn new things,
you also become more aware of what you don't know,
it's very Socratic in that sense.
The other thing that that I've found helpful
is just detaching some of my opinions from my identity,
and trying to anchor my identity much more
in my values instead.
So you know, I would have, if you had asked me
what my identity was, when I was in high school or college,
I would have said, I am a diver.
That was who I was,
it was my screen name on "America Online,"
it was the first thing that anybody knew about me.
I remember my uncle Ira, the Michigan fan uncle,
meeting one of my friends, and asking,
"What do you think Adam's gonna major in in college?"
And my friend said, "Diving."
(Rich and Adam laughs)
And it was so hard for me to walk away from diving,
even though it was time when,
both I think I peaked athletically,
and I also I started to develop other interests.
But it was extremely difficult to let it go
because it was so core to who I thought I was.
And the rethinking of that,
I didn't have the vocabulary for it at the time,
but the rethinking of that for me was to say,
"What is it about diving that I'm so passionate about?"
It's the quest for mastery.
So I really wanna pursue excellence.
That's one of my values, it's the fact that I get
to spend at least 90% of every diving practice,
helping other people with their dives.
Whether it's, you know, encouraging them to try a new dive
that they're afraid of or giving them a coaching tip
because I'm standing at a different angle,
while I'm waiting in line to get on the board.
And that's generosity, and that's a core value of mine.
It's integrity too, it's following through
on my commitments and saying,
"Look, I'm gonna learn these new dives,
I'm gonna show up at practice on these days."
And you can always count on me to do that.
And once I started to realize that there were values
that were attached to that activity, I said,
"Okay, well, I can bring those values
to anything that I do."
And my hope is that people are a little more flexible
in their beliefs and their opinions.
And they really think,
"Okay, my identity is what's important to me,
not the things that I think I need to do today."
That's super interesting.
You know, when I'm listening to you,
to share that, I'm thinking about this gap
that I think a lot of people have between their values,
or perhaps their perceived values
and their ability to execute on them.
I mean, you're somebody who like when you say,
you're gonna do something like you freaking do it,
you have no problem executing
on these ideas that you have, but I think that's real--
Wait, hold on, hello pod, I ain't peddle here,
isn't that the story of your transformed life?
Well, you're gonna,
see you're trying to turn it on me again.
I definitely am, but no, but I look at you and I think,
self discipline has to be your master virtue.
Yeah, I mean I think,
self discipline and a willingness to, like,
I'm not afraid of suffering or doing hard things.
And I'm not afraid of being uncomfortable,
like I welcome that.
And I recognize that that's a skill that I have that maybe
my pain tolerance is a little bit higher than most people,
and I learned that in swimming.
And that served me well, but also been a pitfall in my life.
And I look at you, and that was one of the reasons
why I asked about diving at the outset.
Like, you have this ability to execute on your goals,
like you got a masters and a PhD in three years
at University of Michigan.
There's this story that you always email people back
right away, I've experienced that,
like, I don't know how you do it,
like, there are certain aspects,
like character specific aspects of who you are,
that you seem to have developed mastery over
and whether you learn those as a diver
or as a diligent student, I don't know.
But how can you speak to the person who suffers
from an inability to marry their value systems
with their output or their actions, does that make sense?
It does, it's honestly something I've had a hard time
making sense of, because it's just so foreign to me.
(indistinct)
It's hardwired into you, right?
Yeah, I mean, I don't even think, I don't think
I learned any of the tendencies you described, right?
I think they're just built in, I remember,
if you had a time machine
and you went to meet five year old me,
I had a goal of waking up as early as possible
in the morning so that I could play
with human characters.
I had a whole story that I wanted to play out,
nothing was interfering with that.
The Nintendo thing too, right?
Same, yeah, Nintendo is just laser focused obsession.
And my problem has always been,
how do I lower those attentional filters
so that they're not blinders?
And it's, you know, it's almost like when I meet somebody
who has the opposite challenge,
which I realize is more common than mine.
Like, I'm really, I have no idea
because I don't do this deliberately,
it's just how I'm wired.
I think, I mean, the best thing that I've learned
from trying to study it, is really what I ended up exploring
on procrastination last year.
So I give a whole TED Talk
that's about the surprising virtues
of moderate procrastination for creativity,
I read about that in a book.
And then I find that most people
are not precrastinators like me,
they're really struggling with procrastination
that's hurting their productivity,
that's undermining their romantic relationships,
that's causing them to be unhealthy.
And I went and said, "Okay, I've got to understand
what do we know about the psychology
of preventing procrastination?"
And the light bulb moment
for me was some work by Fuchsia Sora and Tim Petula,
two psychologists who have found that when we procrastinate,
it's not because of being, it's not because of laziness.
And I think you could probably say
this is more broadly true, right?
It's not procrastination, many of the gaps
between people's goals and values and their daily actions,
they're not because they don't wanna work hard,
or they lack you know, some magical amount of grid,
that's a prerequisite for following through.
It's often because of emotions, not time.
And what they're avoiding is not hard work,
they're avoiding a negative emotion
that a particular task stirs up.
So, what I would encourage people to do is to think
about whatever goal that you're not pursuing,
or that you're, you know, whatever habit you're trying
to build that you're falling short on,
and ask yourself what negative emotion is associated,
with the behavior that you wanna do more of,
or the behavior that you wanna stop doing?
And you know, in some cases, it's fear for people, right?
They'll say, I'm afraid of finding out that I can't do it,
and I would rather just put in partial effort
and sandbag it.
And by self handicapping,
I don't have to ever find out if I'm capable or not.
And that way I can believe
that I really have the potential one day.
For other people it's frustration,
it's I tried a bunch of times,
I didn't get the result I wanted,
and I'm tired of banging my head against a brick wall.
And so it's just, it's not worth the effort anymore.
For me, it's boredom.
It turns out, I procrastinate sometimes Rich,
and when I procrastinate because--
Shame on you.
I know, I feel I feel like such a fraud, I'm a hypocrite.
But everyone procrastinate sometimes, right?
It's a normal human behavior.
And when I do it, it's because what fires me up
is intrinsic motivation, the intrinsic motivation
to work on an interesting problem, to help somebody.
And if I have to do something that I think is not exciting,
and that doesn't directly benefit people,
I have zero interest in doing it.
And so systematically, I put off tasks that fall
in that rock solid, that two by two of interesting
and important and what understanding
that has helped me do, is to say,
Okay, I will put off reading a legal contract forever.
And it sounds like you do, too,
based on what your career was like,
it just bores the hell out of me.
And that means when I understand that,
I can manage it better, because I can try to make
that task a little more interesting by calling up a friend
who knows something about the law and say,
"Hey, would you be willing to chat
through a few of my questions as I read this?"
And I know I'm gonna be forced to read it in order to have
the conversation and not waste their time.
You have to recruit a co-conspirator into this.
Yeah, of course, I need an accountability buddy.
Exactly, somebody somebody to force me to get on task,
somebody to do what I would normally do
if this were a different task.
And then the other thing I'll do is I'll just try
to build into reward afterward and say,
"Look, if I finish reading this contract, then you know,
I get to watch my favorite show," which for years,
I had people who would actually delete those shows,
if I didn't live up to my promises.
First, it was college roommates.
And then, I think I remember asking my wife Allison
at some point, you know, can you just delete this
from the DVR because I didn't earn it today.
And that kind of self reward has been pretty motivating
from time to time, so that's a long answer.
But it's the framework that I found most useful
for navigating this dilemma in my own life.
How do you solve it?
Look at you coming back with the questions.
Yeah I wanna learn from you, come on this is I honestly,
I really wanna, let me just explain
what was behind part of my ulterior motivation.
I went on this drive challenge in the fall of 2019,
that I didn't really know what I was getting into.
I got an email invitation saying,
"Hey, can you speak at this event?
It's raising money for charity."
Great, and oh, by the way, Richard Branson is hosting it.
All right, sure. I'll be there.
And I kept getting these emails saying, "Are you training?"
No, I'm not training, Richard Branson is doing
whatever he could do, if he's twice my age.
And, you know, I did claim I was an NCAA athlete,
I'm sure I'm gonna be fine.
You know, I work out five days a week, no problem.
I showed up there and that thing just kicked my ass.
What was it?
It was in, well, it's called the stripe challenge.
And it was it was hiking up and down mountains,
and then swimming across the lake, and then biking.
I think the longest I'd ever bike
before was five or 10 miles,
and we did a 70K bike ride up a mountain,
I was the only one with gym shoes.
I didn't even think to get clips.
Because, yeah whatever I'm sure I can handle it.
And it was one of the hardest things
I've ever done because I came so unprepared,
and I realized almost all my training has,
it's been much more sprint than endurance,
over the past 20 years.
Ever since I became a diver, I went into explosive power,
and I stopped doing distance and endurance,
and I came out of that thinking that was hard,
it was harder than it should have been,
I wanna get better at this.
And you're obviously you are the creme de la creme
when it comes to doing the craziest long term distance
and endurance challenges ever.
And I wanna know, I wanna understand
how do you motivate yourself to do this?
Well, it's similar to how you responded
to the question about procrastination,
like I'm just wired this, I look forward
to it like it's my joy, like I would prefer
to be out of my bike all day than pretty much anything else.
So it's not a chore and it's not something, I mean certainly
there are days that I don't wanna do it,
and you have to rebut you know some resistance
but I would say by and large,
like it's something I look forward to every day
and always have, like I got up, you know,
in high school I was getting up at 4:45
in the morning to go to swim practice like,
it was very goal oriented then in a way
that it isn't really now, it's more lifestyle,
but it brings it, I feel better,
I'm a better person when I'm doing it,
and I enjoy the process of doing it.
So the confusion lies in people thinking
that this is something that I hate,
and I do it anyway, which is not the case.
I buy that and I get it.
I think the mystery for me though,
is there are moments when you're clearly not
in that zone and you persevere anyway.
So I'll give you a concrete example.
Which is we done I think it was like we did an 11 hour hike,
and then we did I don't know it's about,
maybe a mile now is a kilometer swim across the cold lake.
And then we're doing this intense mountain bike ride
that I've just, I don't know how I'm gonna do this.
And I'm guessing from what the changes I made nutritionally
over the next few days for the next bike ride,
I'm guessing my electrolytes were just way off or way low.
But there was a moment when I was riding on the mountain,
and I thought, okay, if I had a choice
between pedaling one more time and dying,
I'm not sure that I would be able to pedal another.
And I've never felt that in my life.
I've always been the person who persists no matter what.
And coming face to face with that wall and saying,
I literally don't think I can do it physically,
you've pushed through that wall, how?
Sure, well, first of all, let's finish this thread,
so you did persist, right?
So you did take another pedal stroke, and you didn't die?
Yeah, but I had to pause for a minute.
And I was like, no, I don't wanna pause,
I don't wanna have to rest.
But you finished the challenge?
Yeah, actually.
And so walk me through the the emotional experience
in the wake of having completed something
that was harder than you thought it was going to be?
It was one of the most exhilarating rushes of my life.
I think I mean, when people talk about runner's high,
this was on a whole nother level, that 70K bike ride,
we got to the top of the mountain,
and I've never taken a drug.
I can only imagine that's what being high feels like?
And are you able to hold on to that feeling?
Oh, no, definitely not, not a chance,
I only get it when working out.
But you can recall it.
I remember it.
In a way.
And also, yeah, I can remember
what that feeling was like, I want it again.
I also I feel close to that group of people
that went through that week with me in a way
that normally would take me years to build trust
and bond because we all suffered together.
Right, there is definitely an intimacy that occurs
when you do something hard with other people together,
that unites you in a way that few other things do.
And the sense of self,
not just at having accomplished something
that was very difficult.
But having pushed through that perceived boundary,
really expands your horizon of what's personally possible.
And I find that to be incredibly intoxicating,
it is like a drug, but it's also a fuel.
And it's something that I need to continually tap into,
to not only remind myself, but also to persist
in this desire to push that envelope of what's possible.
And there's something about that, that satiates me
and makes me whole,
in a way that nothing else in my life does.
Well, you just did.
That was just a masterclass in a motivational interview.
Because you asked me, do I want more of that?
Like, I don't feel like you're trying to convince me.
Right, I'm not convincing you,
and I just shared my experience.
You wanted to understand it.
And I'm not attached to whether you end up
signing up for some event or not.
No, but as I hear myself talk out loud,
I want to be that person, I wanna do more of that.
I think the other, the only thing that honestly
is holding me back is the time commitment.
And that's the piece that also,
I just, I've really gravitated toward the kinds of workouts
and this is reflected in my eating habits too,
that save me time, and allow me to feel like I'm you know,
I'm making good health choices.
But you know, I don't,
the idea that I would commit three or four hours
to exercise when you know, I could work out for an hour.
Like I don't know where I'm gonna find those hours
between family and work.
And so if you can help me think through
that at some other point, that's the one barrier
that I haven't figured out how to crack it.
Right, I think I've got a good challenge in mind for you.
We could take it offline, but I want--
What's the challenge?
I'm very curious.
So have you heard of the 29029 series?
No.
So do you know Jesse Itzler?
Well, you know, Sarah Blakely, right?
Yeah, Sarah was on that challenge actually.
So Jesse started this business called 29029, and it's--
Oh, I just got his calendar, is that what it is?
Yeah, I did, too I got my calendar,
no it's different from that,
it's related but it's a weekend experience
where a group of people descend upon a mountain,
they have a couple of them, COVID threw the whole thing off,
but the idea is that you hike up this mountain,
and then you take the chairlift down,
it's like a ski mountain in the summertime,
or in, you know, warmer months.
And then you continue to do that until you have hiked
the equivalent of Mount Everest, which is 29029 feet.
So it's a very difficult endurance challenge,
but it's also very accessible,
because you do it at your own pace.
It's not a race, you're just hiking, you're not running,
you get a little break when you take the chairlift down.
But it takes like, a long time to do this.
And it's more difficult than I think people realize,
but it's very doable on not a tremendous amount of training.
And so I'm gonna be doing the one in Utah,
and let's see if we can get you a slot for that.
What do you think about that?
It sounds like fun, you're also,
this is immediately appealing,
because it only requires intensity, not consistency, right?
You're not saying I have to go
and become an endurance athlete,
this is just commit for a weekend.
Right, and what's cool about this is that you get
some hardcore athletes who are out there going in,
but for a lot of people that do this challenge,
it's the first hard thing that they've ever done.
And the level of like, sort of self satisfaction,
like it's really amazing to see these people in the wake
of achieving something that they didn't think
that they could, or pushing through that, you know,
boundary that they never have before.
And it's really intoxicating to see that in other people,
and that like group cohesion and sense
of unity and community is really quite something.
That makes so much sense, I think that's the thing
that I miss most about diving.
Aside from just the clarity of knowing exactly
what I needed to work on, and how much progress I could make
if I put the effort in, as opposed to this world
of ambiguity I live in where I do a study,
or I write a book, or I give a TED talk,
and who knows if people are gonna like it,
and even if they like it, if it's gonna make any difference.
I missed that, but I think even more than that,
I miss being part of a team that has a common goal.
And I miss especially with my teammates and the divers
that I got to coach, those breakthroughs,
where all of a sudden they achieve something
that they thought was impossible for them.
And it sounds like you've got
a whole experience orchestrated around that.
Yeah, it's pretty special.
So I'll share some of that information with you afterwards.
I can't wait.
So you spoke at the Nantucket Project
several years ago, right?
Like you were like the tie, everyone loved it,
you were like the top guy, I'm part of that community,
I've spoken at that event a couple times,
I think you were there the year
before my first year attending.
I've known Tom Scott my whole life,
we went to junior high school and high school together.
Wow, I didn't realize that.
Yeah, we grew up together.
And in reading your book and thinking about your work.
I couldn't help but think about Simon Greer,
who's part of the Nantucket Project community,
are you familiar with him and the work
that he's doing in a space similar to your own?
I don't think I am actually,
it just sounds like I should be.
Yeah, he's a guy who has been really devoted
to trying to have difficult conversations with people
who see the world very differently than he does.
And he does these live
in front of people at the Nantucket project,
and he's also done them in his clinical work
where he'll get, you know, Palestinians
and Orthodox Jews together to have a dinner party
and try to bridge the gap.
And I've seen him do this with varying degrees of success.
Like he hosted a conversation at the Nantucket Project
with Candace Owens that I didn't think went very well.
And then I've seen him have a conversation
with Glenn Beck that I thought went, you know, quite well.
So I was just curious if you had known his work,
because it seemed to dovetail with so many other things
that you think about and--
No, clearly I need to, and I will be looking it up
as soon as we wrap our conversations,
right after I suggest a couple of people
that I think you need to meet immediately.
But one of the things that I think is really interesting
about what just happened
is it just suppressed my inner politician.
Because when you said have you heard of this person?
I think it's my job to know everyone who's working
in the space broadly defined that I'm working in right now.
And so my temptation was okay,
well, can I look him up really quickly.
And then, you know, kind of dodge the question,
and not have to admit that I don't know him.
I don't wanna be that person.
No, I haven't heard of this one, tell me more.
You just wrote a whole book
about how it's okay to say, I don't know.
I know, and here I practiced it.
But I still felt that urge to say like,
I don't wanna be that guy,
I also didn't wanna disappoint you,
because you seemed excited
to dig into the relationship between our work.
Right, yeah, that that whole thing went nowhere,
but that's okay.
(Rich laughs)
No, but tell me, no, so here's what I wanna ask you,
now knowing what kind of work he does.
What's the skill that you've picked up from observing him,
for getting people whose views are so different,
to at least be open to hearing each other?
Well, I think it's a two edged sword.
I mean, on the one hand, it fits perfectly,
with what you're saying, which is lead with curiosity,
you know, ask questions, be interested, you know,
refrain from judgment, you know, be present,
like all of these things, I think are crucial,
if you wanna truly, you know, bridge a gap,
and reach a place of better understanding,
I think, where it gets tricky, and I think this is something
that came up for me and reading your book as well,
is the extent to which there's an agenda attached to that.
It's like, "I'm gonna go into this conversation,
and I'm gonna be curious, and I wanna understand,
but really, what I wanna do is still, you know,
get you to admit that you're wrong and I'm right, right?"
So talk to me a little bit about that, because that seems
to be the thing that no one really wants to acknowledge.
And I think that infects the whole, you know, environment.
It does the, I think right away about this work
in consumer psychology by Friestad and Wright,
where they talk about,
they call it the Persuasion Knowledge Model.
And the idea is that once you recognize that somebody
has persuasive intent, a change of meaning occurs.
And now what seemed like a genuine conversation before,
becomes a tactic.
And what seemed like a chance to explore
an open discussion, seems like a situation
where you have to put your guard up.
And I think that happens all the time.
I mean, I find myself both being on the receiving end of it,
and as a cause of it, much more often than I would like.
And I think the practice of motivational interviewing
has started, it's definitely shifted my thinking,
it's started to shift my behavior.
I catch myself doing it more often now in real time,
and sometimes I don't catch it.
And then a friend of mine says,
"Hey, you're lawyering here."
Yep, there we go again.
And when that happens, what I have to step back
and ask myself is okay, are there common values here at all?
Are there any principles that we share?
And if I can't name any,
I have to get curious and find them.
And then the second question I wanna ask is,
whatever values we agree upon,
is there anything I can learn about or inquire about,
that will help the other person better clarify those values,
or how to live those values?
And where I run into trouble sometimes
is either I'm convinced
that they have the wrong values to begin with.
You know, like when I talk to somebody who says,
"Well, you know, I know it's selfish not to wear a mask,
but you know, we're an individualistic country."
I'm like, I can't in good faith support living in a country
where you're allowed to harm other people,
in fact that violates our value of freedom.
Right, you can't threaten someone else's freedom,
then you're not in a free country anymore.
So I have a hard time with that.
And I also have a hard time with,
when I am just dead set on the fact
that the way that they're trying to live their values,
is not gonna work out well for them
or for the people that they care about.
And those are the moments
where I get stuck going back into prosecutor mode,
but I think the rest of the time,
where I think I've had some luck.
And some, I guess, made some progress,
has been when I've said, you know what Rich?
Let me just start the conversation by recognizing
that I have a bad habit of trying to change your mind,
and I'm trying to get out of that habit.
And so what I really wanna do here is interview you,
I wanna learn from you,
I wanna understand your viewpoint better.
And I do have a vested interest in people having open minds,
because I believe that that's foundational for learning.
And so you might catch my questions
being a little bit tilted in the direction of,
you know, are there are there circumstances
that would shift your opinion a little bit?
And that's not because I'm trying
to drive you in a particular direction,
it's because I'm invested in a personal project,
of building a more mentally flexible world right now.
And if you object to that project, I wanna hear that too,
because I need to be flexible.
And when I've started with that kind of disclaimer upfront,
it's I think, both sent the right message
to the other person, but it's also reinforced,
like that's me activating cognitive dissonance
if I screw up,
and then I'm more likely to hold myself accountable.
It is interesting, how reluctant we are to wanna be wrong.
Like, it shouldn't be such a big deal to say,
"I don't know," or like, "Wow, I was wrong about that,"
like to be able to pivot,
I mean, certainly, you know, in the public sphere,
or if you're a politician, it's seen as anathema
for you to change your mind.
You know, it does feel like in order to cultivate
a healthy culture, we need to incentivize open mindedness,
on a broader scale, and de-stigmatize this idea
of not knowing and of saying, I'm wrong, it's okay, right?
Like our ego attachment to that is so powerful.
Yeah, I think it is.
And I don't know how to do that societally.
I've tried to figure out what can we do, you know,
in schools and workplaces, even in families, right?
And in cultures or systems that we have
a little bit more direct influence over.
And I think the news there is actually pretty good, right?
That when students are taught,
that admitting what they don't know,
is actually part of the learning process,
they become more curious than intellectually humble,
they actually learn more and do better on tests.
And so creating that kind of psychological safety
in your classroom, for anyone to say,
"Hey, I didn't understand that."
And that's not a sign that I lack intelligence.
It's a sign that I wanna pick up knowledge.
That seems to be a healthy attitude
for a classroom environment.
Workplace, it's the same thing, right?
Let's stop making expertise the currency of success.
Let's say what we wanna do is recognize
that knowledge is not a weapon to wield,
it's a resource to share.
And that means if you lack knowledge,
you should not only be given permission,
you should be encouraged to go to people
who might have a perspective that you lack,
and let them know what your ignorance is,
so that you can try to fill some of the gaps
in your knowledge.
And I think that starts with leaders not punishing people,
for asking questions or for being wrong.
It starts with, in many cases,
just doing something really basic, which is,
don't just reward results,
don't just reward success and punish failure.
Put people in a situation where you reward a thoughtful,
curious, decision making process.
And that means we could even celebrate
a good decision process with a bad outcome.
Because maybe that was a smart experiment to run,
and we learned something from it.
And maybe we should stop rewarding good outcomes
with bad processes, because that's just luck.
And you don't wanna repeat that,
you wanna rethink your process.
But the idea being that this is trainable,
we are malleable in this regard.
We're not born as somebody who loves to be proved wrong,
like we can create incentives around this
in our organizations and in our interpersonal lives,
to cultivate a little bit more of this,
and to the extent that we can do that,
we become, we stress testing our own ideas,
we become better, more creative thinkers,
we become better conversationalist, we become better,
challenge network members, for our friends and our peers,
and ultimately, just be better humans and citizens,
is that fair?
(both laugh)
It's more than fair, that's a hell of an elevator pitch
for what I hope people take away from this set of ideas.
And yeah, I don't think any of that resistance
is hardwired, right?
There's no reason why you couldn't create,
a culture or a community where people
are punished if they don't admit they're wrong.
And I think we just gotten that backward
in a lot of parts of the world.
And, you know, I don't know about you,
but I would rather reward people
who are interested in developing competence,
than hold up people who are full
of overconfidence as exemplars to follow.
Yeah, you and me both my friend?
Well, I think that's a great place to end it.
But before we land, the plane, I think it would be helpful
or instructive for the listener or the viewer to have,
I think the idea that I wanna leave people with is,
if you feel yourself resistant to a different idea,
or there's a certain personality out there that really,
gets your blood boiling.
Like what's the first step for that person to take,
in terms of trying to soften a little bit
so that perhaps they could have
a more productive interaction?
I think what I would recommend is to treat
that emotional response as a rough draft.
It's the first draft of how you're gonna feel.
And I've never done anything
where my first draft was any good.
Where I didn't wanna constantly revise and improve it.
Whether it was the first time I tried to dive
or the first draft of a book that I had to throw out,
or the TED Talk that I rewrote from scratch
over and over and over again,
and then everybody who achieves excellence in any domain
knows that it's the constant rewriting and rethinking,
and revising that makes you good and helps you get better.
And I think once you recognize, hey, you know what?
Feeling threatened or hating somebody else,
or being offended by somebody else,
that's a first draft of a response,
then you can go and write a revision, and ask yourself,
"Okay, is that a teachable moment?
Did I just learn something
about what activates my prosecutor instincts?
Or what puts me in a preaching mindset?"
And if I understand that better,
then I have more control over what mindset I landed?
Beautifully put, I think you practiced that
in the conclusion of your book, where you basically,
in this very really funny and like meta way,
like you basically, your conclusion is a red line.
And that shows like the changes and the thoughts that went
into various drafts of how you wanted to conclude this book,
which is not about conclusions,
but about remaining open to new ideas and possibilities.
I'm so glad you got a kick out of that,
because it was one of the things
that was most resistant to rethinking when I wrote the book.
I had argument after argument with this challenge network
of brilliant former students who read early drafts,
and I said, nonfiction book does not need a conclusion.
Like it's not a book report.
And anything else I had to say I would have already said it.
And they just, they were so thoughtful
and convincing me that, "Yeah, you know what?
I get that you're writing a book about rethinking,
you don't want the rethinking to end,
but the last page of this book is the beginning
of conversations we're all gonna have.
And it's the start of a reflection process.
And don't you wanna give us a springboard to that?"
(Adam roars)
All right, fine, maybe you're onto something here.
But very begrudgingly, and then I said,
"Well, yeah, you know how I could do that?
a blank page.
I'm just, you're gonna turn to the epilogue,
and there's gonna be nothing there,
and it's gonna be the the canvas for you
to do your rethinking on."
And they said, "Yeah, that's a cop out,
we can't let you do it.
Why don't you show us your own rethinking?"
I was like, "All right, I get that this would be very meta,
and I could have some fun with it.
But I really just wanna be done, I like closure."
I'm not living the principles I wrote about in the book,
I need to rethink this.
Right, well I thought it was great,
I'd never seen anything like that in a book.
And it's the perfect book to end in that manner,
in this kind of circular way that leaves it open ended,
and yet still create some finality for the reader.
So well done, I love the book,
I so appreciate the thoughtfulness
that you put into your work, the care, you are a true giver.
And it's been great to spend some time with you.
So thank you.
Well, that is overly generous,
I wanna thank you for really getting me to reflect
on a bunch of assumptions that I haven't questioned enough.
And I'm also just in addition to this being
an exhilarating conversation,
with a different kind of intensity than endurance sport,
I'm also just thrilled that I got to make a new friend.
Yeah cool, you and me both, I look forward
to meeting you in person at some time at some point.
And let's try to figure out
that endurance challenge thing, all right?
Thank you, and I wanna hear what your next challenges are
and figure it out if I can be helpful with them.
All right, that would be great, thanks.
Thanks Rich.
So if you wanna connect with Adam, @AdamMGrant on Twitter,
pick up the book at your favorite bookseller
or go to adamgrant.net, right?
Is that the places that you wanna direct people?
You got it.
Alright man, let's do this again.
I look forward to it.
All right cool, thanks Adam, appreciate you.
Thank you.
Peace.